French and dead A New Perspective on the
apocalypse and a fan favorite return
here's everything you need to know
before you get a taste of The Walking
Dead Daryl Dixon
when The Walking Dead took his final bow
in the winter of 2022 many of his
characters had satisfying endings and
yet they remain a few unfinished loose
ends I begged for completion Negan and
Maggie are taking Manhattan in The
Walking Dead dead City while
star-crossed lovers Michonne and Rick
remain separated by Miles and Powerful
enemies alike a situation that will
hopefully be improved during their own
spin-off as for Daryl he had a much more
subdued exit from the series he tells
his close friend Carol during a
soul-searching heart to heart as he's
heading out solo he then leaves the
Commonwealth behind to seek it out and
thus a spin-off was born The Walking
Dead dowel Dickson will track Daryl's
Further Adventures to the Untamed
unsettled zombie-laden world and through
cities far away from Alexandria as Carol
points out when they part in The Walking
Dead He's still looking for something he
doesn't have but it seems that the
Walking Dead Daryl Dixon will try giving
him at least a little time to find it
as established by the series finale of
The Walking Dead Daryl has wandered far
abroad from the Alexandria he once knew
apparently the show will take him even
farther than anyone thought a blurb
attached to the official in production
trailer released by AMC in may also has
a brief plot description attached it
reads Daryl Dixon Journeys across a
broken but resilient friend as he hopes
to find the way back home a longer blur
released by AMC in February 2023 as
archived by deadline explains that Daryl
will wash it up on Francis Shores and
have absolutely no memory as to how he
got there and why how did you come to be
in France what a bad decision
he will find himself teaming up with a
human revolutionary force that believes
that Daryl arrived to fulfill a kind of
Prophecy they believe that he's a
foretold messenger there to safely
escort a boy named Laurent to his
position as leader of a Revival of
humanity Norman Reedus told
Entertainment Weekly in September 2022
it's going to be way different the
story's way different the characters are
way different there's a different tone
there's different light there's a
different sound it's a whole different
vibe producer Greg nicotero has said
basically the same thing telling
Entertainment Weekly this is probably
the closest to a standalone show you
will ever get the goal isn't just to see
Daryl in exotic and new locations but to
explore a wholly different world
obviously Norman Reedus will head up the
cast of The Walking Dead Daryl Dixon but
till the rock does have been casting
pivotal roles which are slated to drive
the series forward the deadline reports
that radius will be joined by a ton of
new actors and actresses on his perilous
Journey clemon's perezi will play Isabel
he becomes a companion to Daryl's
Journey she heads a progressive
religious group enjoying her time with
Daryl will be forced to confront her
checked life before joining the sect
Adam the guy test will play Quinn an
expat from England whose dirty dealings
have made him a major face on the black
market he runs an illicit club that will
no doubt factor into the story other
confirmed cast members include and
Sharia Enrique buenae Leica Blanc
franchard androman Levy but there's one
name missing from that list that a lot
of fans were hoping to see Daryl Dixon
entered production as a spin-off
starring fun favorite Duo Daryl and
Carol with co-star Melissa McBride opted
to sit it out 12 years is a grueling
schedule and she wanted to take some
time off so she's doing that and she
deserves it in June 2023 however Jeffrey
Dean Morgan tweeted a production photo
of readers and McBride together teasing
that Carol might be part of the spin-off
after all
according to deadline The Walking Dead
Daryl Dixon will see writer and producer
David zabel taking the role of
showrunner he assumed his position in
April when Angela Kang changed her role
within the project Kanki was set to run
the series after serving a showrunner on
The Walking Dead for multiple seasons
will serve solely as an executive
producer the rest of the series
executive production team includes Abel
Scott M gimple Norman Reedus former The
Walking Dead director and actor Greg
nicotero Brian buckrath and Daniel
Percival there's no word currently as to
who will be serving as a series
directing team nor who has written the
Show's first batch of episodes viewers
will likely have to wait until the show
gets closer to being released before AMC
divulges that information
that's fans gearing up for the premiere
of Daryl Dixon you have to wonder
whether this will be a one-off season or
if it will grow legs or the long-running
main series did if I don't make it back
wanted to know I tried well good news
zombie lovers AMC evidently sees so much
promise in the show or realizes has
enough story to tell that it committed
to keeping it on the air for Beyond just
one season at the 2023 San Diego
Comic-Con AMC studios president of
entertainment Dan McDermott announced
that his Network had already ordered a
season two of The Walking Dead Daryl
Dixon saying we're thrilled to double
down on Daryl as we bring the apocalypse
to France
in May 2023 Walking Dead fans are
treated to a behind the scenes video
letting everyone know that Daryl Dixon
was definitely in production giving
viewers brief overhead shots of a French
city and of Walkers roaming the streets
it also gave a short glimpses of Norman
Reedus as Daryl in July 2023 AMC
announced that The Walking Dead Daryl
Dixon will debut on both the AMC cable
channel and as AMC plus streaming
service on September 10 2023 at 9pm
foreign